home turf means a lot when it's predator
versus prey hunting for answers after
finishing the movie here's how it all
went down warning spoilers ahead for
prey
though hulu's prey is the fifth mainline
film in the predator series its story
predates every one of its predecessors
set in north america in 1719 the film
follows comanche warrior naru played by
amber mid thunder who encounters the
alien warrior while out scouting
things take a violent turn when a group
of european trappers and soldiers in
truth culminating in a climactic battle
between nauru and the aoja who's been
tormenting her tribe most predator
stories involve teams of commandos
criminals or otherwise highly trained
individuals facing off against the
yautja usually with only one or two
making that out alive while many of the
supporting characters in movies like
predator and predators make valiant
stands against the aliens they almost
always perish in the end the same fate
befalls many of the comanche hunters in
prey but every member of the group plays
a part in ultimately bringing the beast
down with each encounter nauru and the
other members of her tribe learn more
and more about the predator observing
when it does and doesn't kill clues are
into the creature's thermal vision the
way its laser-guided weapon system works
and its tendencies as a hunter in this
way every comanche character who dies to
the beast contributes to its ultimate
demise imbuing nauru with the tools and
knowledge she needs
this morning in the sky
i saw a sign the sacrificial group
approach stands in stark contrast to the
european faction in the film who possess
immense resources and more advanced
weapons than the comanches but who seem
incapable of learning from their
failures and fighting the yautja rather
than adapt to the predator's methods or
strategize together in any meaningful
way they stubbornly employ the same
stale tactics and put an unhealthy
amount of trust in their guns which
ultimately fail
throughout prey nauru's older brother
tabe shows himself to be a caring
sibling who believes deeply in his
sister but also desperately wants to
protect her at one point in the film he
tells nauru that he used her exact plan
to kill the mountain lion they were
hunting and that she successfully
weakened it before falling unconscious
and being carried back to the village he
clearly thinks that she's capable of
becoming a great hunter and he wants to
build her confidence in a culture that
discourages her hunting i don't think it
was a bear nahru behaves in some pretty
brash and bullheaded ways early on in
prey she goes off all on her own to hunt
the predator before fully understanding
what she's up against through her
encounters with the alien however she
grows in both her courage and her
cleverness finally putting all the
pieces together to become the hunter
she's destined to be in this way her
eventual victory over the predator not
only marks her as a respected protector
of her people but it also symbolizes the
end of her own coming-of-age hunt
sadly tabe becomes the final martyr in
the comanches battle against a predator
as he and naru stand together searching
for their invisible foe tabe realizes
that he's the one the yautja is after
and he says somberly to his sister
thinks i'm the threat
this is as far as i've gone in this
moment nabu has finally become a master
hunter in her brother's eyes he knows
there's no way out for him but he also
seems completely confident that his
sister will be able to do what the rest
of their tribe could not when naoru does
ultimately vanquish the predator she
seems to have mixed feelings about the
whole ordeal there's a clear sense of
pride at having defeated the beast that
so many others fell to but she also
looks beaten down by the trauma and loss
of the fight at least she brings a bit
of her brother into the final showdown
with her as she echoes his final words
to the yautja itself just before
delivering the killing flow this is as
far as you go
after seeing the predator kill so many
others from her tribe and slaughter a
small army of european trappers that
will realize is that the only way to
defeat the creature is to outsmart it
she captures the leader of the european
group and uses him as live bait she
cleverly allows him to get a weapon
making him look like more of a threat to
the predator and therefore drawing the
alien out she also ingests some medicine
to shield herself from the predator's
thermal vision a strategy she picks up
earlier on the film once the alien
reveals itself naru uses a point-blank
pistol shot to knock off the creature's
helmet which she promptly steals after
that naru lures the predator back to a
spot she knows well which is laden with
deep hidden mud pits having seen that
brute force and fighting skills are
useless against the foe as physically
powerful as the yautja she finds other
methods to shock and surprise
in the end she proves that being the
strongest in a fight doesn't
automatically make you the best hunter
prey drives home one of the film's
recurring themes and that's the
inefficacy of advanced technology in the
face of superior intelligence and skill
midway through the movie nauru realizes
that the yautja's handheld spear gun is
connected to the triangular targeting
apparatus on the alien's helmet in past
predator films the red dots of the
targeting device have typically heralded
a blast from the iconic shoulder mounted
plasma cannon but no such weapon appears
in prey that doesn't matter though as
the homing spear gun winds up being just
as deadly as any laser blast
in the end the predator is killed by a
shot from his own gun as nauru sets up
the targeting apparatus to aim at the
creature's head
it doesn't recognize that the lasers
have been activated so when it fires a
bolt at nauru the yautja is surprised to
see the projectile loop back around to
pierce its own skull clearly the homing
device is a powerful weapon as is the
pistol nauru uses to dislodge it and yet
these examples of more advanced
technology come with their share of
caveats the pistol jams and refuses to
fire at different points and the
technological superiority of the
predator's gun ultimately becomes his
undoing by using these weapons as tools
but never letting them supersede her
natural talents as the europeans do
nauru shows that no technology is a
replacement for training and intellect
nara returns home covered in green alien
blood and carrying the severed head of
the predator which she deposits on the
ground for all to see
the whole tribe begins to celebrate
mirroring the behavior seen when her
brother returned earlier in the film
with the body of the slain mountain lion
it seems that nauru will finally be
accepted as the skilled hunter she is i
think this creature
is a hunter regardless of everyone
else's opinions naru is clearly changed
by her experience maybe it's a
realization that growing up and taking
responsibility involves more exhaustion
than glamour or maybe it's a fact that
no dead predator can stop the
encroaching wave of european
colonialists taking over the comanches
land
while the predator itself is a definite
antagonist in prey it's far from the
film's only villain the ecological and
cultural war brought by white settlers
is alluded to very early on when aru's
dog gets caught in a european trap like
the predator the trappers are
interlopers in a landscape they don't
fully respect or understand and while
they all get wiped out in prey the early
18th century was only the start of a
long process of land theft against the
comanches
you killed the buffalo after delivering
the head of the predator and aru says
that the tribe must move towards more
protected ground as their current
location isn't safe perhaps she
anticipates that comanche being blamed
for the ouches european massacre or
maybe she simply wants to be prepared
for potential invaders either way it's a
stark realization and what's an
otherwise celebratory moment for nauru
along with the predator's head naru
presents a flintlock pistol she acquires
as a gift to the elders of her tribe
when the chief inspects the gun the
camera shows an inscription that reads
rafael adelini with the year 1715
written underneath dedicated fans of the
predator franchise will recognize this
as an easter egg though the pistol's
inclusion and prey also brings up some
interesting questions about the
canonical predator timeline at the end
of predator 2 after making his way on
board the yautja ship lieutenant mike
harrigan is given the exact same
flintlock pistol by none other than the
leader of the yautja hunting party it
seems to be a gift and a symbol of
harrigan's skill as a warrior as the
predators then leave without killing the
policemen because prey takes place just
four years after the inscription of the
gun it makes some sense why it would
show up but some things about its
inclusion don't quite add up for
starters how do the predators get the
pistol back now that naru has it is it
sheer luck that somewhere down the line
they kill a descendant of hers or is the
implication that the yautja come back
for naru since she's proven herself to
be a capable warrior either way prey
seems to retcon the comic book predator
1718 which relays a different account to
the pistol's origin
in the comic book predator 1718 readers
are introduced to pirate captain rafael
adelini who's searching for treasure off
the coast of papua new guinea with his
crew when they encounter a predator the
alien eventually kills the whole pirate
crew including adeline but not before
the captain gives the hunter his pistol
as a show of respect
clearly prey changes that history the
character who gives the pistol to nauru
in the film is credited as raphael
making it pretty clear that the gun is
his that effectively erases the entire
predator 1718 comic from the series
canon though its canonical status was
never fully secure still that change has
some interesting ramifications for the
overarching predator lore for starters
how the yautja get the pistol back
remains unknown at least for now could
prey become just the start of a
historical predator saga the possibility
is definitely there
prey director dan trachtenberg has
revealed that the film was conceived as
a full theatrical release however the
decision was later made to make prey a
hulu exclusive in an interview with
uproxx trachtenberg said we made it to
be a big theatrical experience and on
the downside it's not being released
that way so you can't see it in the
theater but on the upside the thing
you're getting straight into the living
room is a giant theatrical experience
it's not like a straight video dumping
ground it's like this is a real movie
and it is this creature's first time on
earth trying to find the most worthy
opponent given the critical reactions to
prey that goal has clearly been met but
the streaming release also has some
interesting potential implications for
the franchise's future it's no secret
that 2018's the predator fell woefully
short at the box office which may also
have played a part in the decision to
release prey directly to hulu now that
the film has returned the series to a
place of honor there's a chance for more
expansion via streaming basically it's
just a kind of creative shake-up that
the franchise needed could the story
continue in sequels maybe in other eras
only time will tell
[Music]
you